[Music]
thank you
this is
foreign
Russia and Vladimir Putin depend on and
in fact need the Wagner group to carry
out Russian foreign policy not just in
Ukraine but around the world and I think
this Rift has exposed some real
divisions in Russian command and control
and you know frankly it's it's made
Putin look quite weak
what's up
[Music]
here's something of a Frankenstein's
monster and it takes on a life of its
own he's not reliable he's not a member
of the Armed Forces per se he may have
had a license at some point from Putin
to kick out to an extent in order to
shock the Russian army into more
effective War fighting however that has
gone Way Beyond anything that Putin
would ever have envisaged now
thank you
for Wagner this looks like it might be
the end Wagner troops who did not
participate in this Uprising are going
to be integrated into the ministry of
Defense apparently everyone else is
being dismissed but not charged
[Music]